[Music]
if you're at all serious about
counter-strike
you have an opinion about zeus oh here
we go zeus though
apparently that's something he's captain
after all he is one of the most
controversial in-game leaders
ever to touch the game during his
17-year long career
zeus has served as a founding member of
one of esports's most
fabled dynasties he's made it to the
finals of not one
not two not three but four cs go majors
he's been kicked from the org he helped
create banded together a group of
misfits made the tournament run of a
lifetime and earned
back his spot on the very roster that
dropped him to begin with
zeus has stood atop the world of
competitive counter-strike for over a
decade and chances are you think he
sucks that in addition to being an
actual bot
he isn't some brazen barbaric visionary
with god to your gut instincts
he's well kind of a joke
[Music]
this is the story of the most divisive
mastermind counter-strike has ever had
i just say all of myself i love you
and second god help me
and i won't measure
[Music]
when it comes to counter-strike there
are few competitors who've been around
for as long as danilo zeus teslengo
born in kharkiv ukraine this boisterous
in-game leader is also
shy of simple the single most famous
player the cis has ever produced
[Music]
like a lot of og 1.6 zeus's counter
strike career kicked off back in the
early to mid 2000s
singapore from pro 100 to virtus pro to
forza dts gaming and kirchnet
zeus spent over five years cutting his
teeth on a variety of rosters
it wasn't until 2010 that he became a
founding member of what would quickly
become the crown jewel of cis orcs
navi commando
alongside such legendary names as edward
and the fabled opera marcolov
zeus played an instrumental role in
helping navi to usher in their era but
despite that success
here's the thing zeus wasn't a fragger
he was a thinker
a leader but that's not to say he was
calm cold or calculating
he was brutish aggressive and emotive
he played with his heart as much as he
did his mind
he is a real man he is very
strong person he is the kindest one
in the world
with zeus at the helm and star x guiding
him every step of the way
navi quickly solidified themselves as
gods of the game
they weren't just the cis's finest they
were titans
a world power whose dominance remains a
thing of legend to this day
by 2011 navi had become the only 1.6
roster
ever to win four majors in succession
and were largely considered to be the
greatest force the game had
ever seen alive and kicking neo takes
down starix there is zeus on goose and
he manages to get to
edward up close and zeus will finish it
off and navi will win the intel extreme
masters world championship
back to back champions for the first
time in the intelligent masters
history unfortunately following the much
anticipated release of cs go in august
of 2012
navi's reign of tyranny came to a halt
they were still formidable but tasked
with learning an entirely new game
and having come to it rather late the
ukrainian super squad
struggled
by the time the first cs go major rolled
around in late 2013
navi had reached an all-time low despite
being kings of the world a year prior
zeus's roster simply hadn't adapted to
global offensive the way others had
[Music]
if zeus was going to restore navi to
their former glory he'd need to put his
nose to the grindstone
come 2014 they'd finally found a
suitable replacement for markloff an
up-and-coming opera known as guardian
and were starting to show signs of
progress slowly but surely
navi began to climb they may have placed
dead last in katavitse
[Music]
but cologne saw them eek their way into
the top eight
fnatic are in the semi-finals now we are
gonna go out
and by dreamhack winter they'd earned
their rightful place in the final four
lined up and ziplex has got three of
them already with 30 seconds left to go
penny go all the way
no he can't navi has done it in two maps
and they've done it in some style they
send out a message to the other
semi-finalists
that they're here and they're here to
stay by 2015
zeus had proven that despite being a
simple meat and potatoes kind of
strategist
he was a world class igl what's more
he'd become known for having a highly
idiosyncratic leadership style
what [ __ ] talent is zeus working with
he's working with
guys where on his team i'd argue there
might not be any superstar player how
are they getting so many t rounds how is
he doing it
here's the best part of it it's pure
execution
he was a leader in the game and now it's
all on shroud here 17 seconds and he
goes for the fight he goes down
and now we are going to win in 16 14
and you can tell the impact on cloud
line there
oh wow and he was a mentor and caregiver
outside of the server
foreign
zeus was just one of those people who
was born to be a leader
he wasn't even that big brains he just
had a knack for rallying players
together and
getting them to perform out of game zeus
is a charismatic
larger than life figure i mean you can
see him literally yelling on comms to
his players
now whether it's for something they did
that he didn't like or something they
did that he did like
well it depends on the day in game
however
his leadership style or his igling
strats if you look at his t
sides he's super well known for holding
his team back
probing looking for holes and then
sometimes
literally at the last second exploding
onto a site he'd been on na'vi since day
one
and despite handing over many of his
in-game responsibilities to starex who'd
become navi's coach in march of 2015
his love for teamwork was eternal
[Music]
and despite losing all three of the
year's majors to an absurdly dominant
envious
2016 was the year that zeus was finally
able to lead his team to first place
finishes at a myriad of premier
tournaments
not to mention the fact that he'd led
the cis to its first ever cs go major
final
to this site and it's an ideal situation
for them but nbk removes zeus and it's
not looking good
oh and a second headshot there flamie
going to be gone
and there it
[Applause]
and the is title in the world for three
of these players the first for pennies
and eight
quarter victory fortunately navi's
penultimate finish at the major
only made them hungrier zeus led his
roster to top four finish after top four
finish before charging into
counter-strike's first
million dollar major in columbus as
feisty hopefuls
and sure enough they delivered
overwhelmed by edward and now it's down
to fryeburg and he goes out as well
the bomb does get planted but there's
more than enough time for the defuse to
come through
that's gonna be it ladies and gentlemen
now b they make yet another semi-final
16 to 10 years they defeat nip and i
dare say it
it's over navier in the grand final the
second
straight time for the second major in a
row
zeus led his squad to the grand finals
with fnatic out of the picture and
arguably the best opera in the world at
his disposal the pressure was on for
zeus to earn navi their first
cs go major they haven't quite ever
lived up to their billing they've come
close they were in the final of the last
major
and weren't able to close the deal it
took a long time long road for us to get
here
i think we are ready to crush every
single team at this event
unfortunately it was in that final
against a group of especially explosive
brazilians that things
slowly started going to [ __ ] they've got
almost no health he could definitely do
this he looks for the shot he gets the
one kill into there
picking it up and luminosity winning
on mirage
[Applause]
after letting the first map slip out of
their grasp navi entered the second on
the verge of complete and utter collapse
and now it is a one-on-two taco looking
to see if he could close it out here and
win it
for the brazilians it's gonna be a big
turn around there hits the head shot on
zeus and now it's a one-on-one
guardian versus taco it may just be
destined to
it's luminosity winning their first
major championship
[Music]
following columbus it felt as if navi
were a bit shaken up
they failed to win anything in
preparation for the next major in
cologne and despite topping their group
suffered a quarter-final exclusion at
the hands of the ukraine's biggest
up-and-coming star
simple simple so commit to the plan no
fades it out smartly so gets edward and
he knows that they're trying to wrap
back around onto him
smoke to allow him the freedom of
movement and also the chance to peak
spots the gun barrel
of zeus he's going to try and catch him
out lurk up closely he sees him coming
nice shot by simple there's two
one to go seized they don't know they're
there
he keeps it for 13 rounds with it i'm
sorry navi
your chances they're gone again it's
gonna have to be a hell of a second half
from you who still has a pistol he
cannot play this he cannot fade it out
nitro his presence knowing it long
and guardian's aware of it that's the
chance to advance it overnight
man oh man what a round to pull this
back and liquid are going to the
semi-finals
unbelievable coming out of cologne some
worried that zeus's career was waning
sitting just shy of 30 years old his
window to win a major was closing
fast he'd never been an especially
talented fragger
but as navi's results got worse so too
did the bullying
to some zeus had become a veritable bot
it must be soon there's only there's
less than 10 seconds at this point
zeus is burning he's burning no what is
going on colors actually gonna
burn zeus alive what he didn't realize
nothing just happened
and he's just gonna get shot in the back
here by flamie
[Music]
walks in between his train but he really
should i have no idea how he's still
alive somebody should call sierra at
this point
hiding behind the train here and if they
jump down
oh flamey gonna get that kill with the
molotov the flames catches him
what's worse the community had started
to doubt his ability to do the one
thing he'd always been known for be a
leader
despite all the chances navi had been
given they always found a way to fall
short
i think you could make a pretty strong
case that navi natas vincer the current
five-man lineup they have
is arguably the best team in the history
of cs go not to win the major
and it was right then just as the
community wrote navi off as a sinking
ship
that had happened
after donning the black and yellow for
nearly a decade the very orc that zeus
had worked so hard to put on the map
kicked him navi was his baby
given that navi had pretty much taken
him out to pasture and the fact that his
stock was at an all-time low
the expectation was that zeus would
simply settle for what he'd achieved up
until that point
hang up his mouse and keyboard and ease
into retirement
the thing is zeus wasn't done he'd
sworn that he was going to win a cs go
major so he did a very difficult thing
something that no one who'd come as far
as he had would ever
think to do start over yeah
[Music]
he commanded now it goes without saying
that gambit
weren't of the same caliber as a navi it
was clear from the get-go
that it would be an uphill battle since
all zeus had to work with was veteran
russian player doja and a trio of
kazakhstani misfits
[Music]
and before long that work had started to
pay off
that'll keep them alive with a chance
but only a hope in hell because it's one
versus three
he's down to 25 bomb planted in gambit
they're your dreamhack open champions
what a performance from them upsetting
so many teams all the way through and
like you say building
for the major i'm impressed this team is
very exciting to watch
he said if you want to win the titles
you have to
leave this game when you sleep you have
to think about game
and whole day must be about csgo yes
come the atlanta major in early 2017
gambit were brimming with confidence
and he's going to hit the headshot on
adrian but it's a 1v3 they're going to
score him up
16 to 8 at the end
of the first map of the major i mean
absolutely amazing isn't it it's
it's true counter-strike major fashion
there's always an upset
so many people to fight against three
players how do you avoid the triple p
coming in
the bomb i think it might be being
defused gonna get he's gonna get and
hobbit hold things down
gambit the last round 16 to 14 they may
get to the fox theater
unfortunately they just didn't have the
grit to go all the way
they have the nades zeus hit some god
tier headshots right now he happens to
be named after one but
at the same time it's done plenty of
time
they all have kits fnatic will be able
to get the defuse and move on to the
semifinals
but as far as the community was
concerned a top 8 finish was the best
that
zeus and his band of underdogs could
hope for even as their tournament
results improved
gambit entered the krakow major as an
unknown variable who weren't expected to
beat the tournament's top teams
but now when zeus joins you can just
definitely tell like how he has
transformed this team into a team that
has the potential of winning best of
threes versus some of the best teams in
the world we're not talking sk's here
i still think that they're a little bit
far from beyond for that but you know
potentially upsetting
some other big names here but zeus
wasn't ready to roll over
almost no chance that he could do this
he's boxed in
and sure enough there it is and days for
miles sports at least here at the
beginning
16-10 victory for gambit in their first
match of the major very early but you do
a quick rotate over from the b site and
zeus will start things off
just trade kills all over the place
until hobbit shows up and gets a
treadmill quad
okay then avid the man is here to play
such an explosive team of dread at least
went down and he almost got the kill on
dozier then
but stuck back here and he's gonna go
down harvard not even waiting for it
16-6
as gambit take down g2 on cash
or whatever you want to call it
well they're up 2-0 in the groups
they're one map away from a spot in the
top eight
spot at that legendary status
maintaining that legendary status
and of course playing one of the biggest
stages in the world let's get the
molotov in position therefore instead
he's waiting to bait hobbit out snacks
takes damage from flames
to balaton therefore puts the nade in
position and hobbit swings around to
close the kill
gambits despite the team of vertis pro
being at home take hole position into
the playoffs the first team to qualify i
wouldn't have expected it especially if
it's so long since we've really seen an
international event from them
absolutely who would have thought 3-0
for gambit after going 5-0
down as well somehow some way
gambit finished first in groups earning
themselves a quarter-final face-off
against an olaf-led fanatic who everyone
expected would crush
zeus can you promise me to make
something really crazy if you want this
measure
cut your hair make funny video
dance and scream maybe zebs i love you
you take it's like a trophy and say
zeus i love you
[Music]
but uh they didn't however hover still
holding down the position
crimso takes down hobart as well flusha
though two week two hp
and now he's dead adren on the bottom
side very responsible the double peaks
coming in
cabinet gaming will make their way to
their semi-finals
beautiful stuff from them composure
great counter strike
we saw classes we saw everything james
for them to be in this position
at first people thought their whole run
was a fluke as if gambit were drunken
brawlers stumbling into winds out of
sheer luck
and yet as they got deeper and deeper
into the tournament
it became clear that there was a method
to zeus's madness
but i think zeus understood his team
hasn't been deeper to major before he's
got young and inexperienced players like
mo
and hobbit and he needs basically to get
comfort to get what he prepared what his
game plan is and execute that he's going
to win by executing not by having the
better players in theory at least going
into these matches
zeus was simply ham fisting his way to
victory and
against all odds it was working but
still stuck by fact the entire team's
still alive
but gavitay know where he is grenades
additionals when they sailing and
there it is garbage they win the first
map against australis overpass is theirs
we have an advantage in this series in
the semi-finals here
unbelievable turn of events but it's not
over yet
even when the going got tough and his
team was desperately in need of
inspiration
zeus was there ready to lead in the most
unconventional way imaginable time
zeus and hobbits are not long for this
world
there isn't really a coordinated attempt
i think zeus is just using this round
to talk to his team he's standing in
t-spawn at the moment can have a much
longer
tactical timeout get a team on the
correct page
because
still taking the time out still more to
talk about ct's it is getting
very tense indeed now just down to
device against three players
who are playing perfectly keeping
themselves out of these positions
they're not peaking
at all whatsoever as they shouldn't be
and that's device now with nothing left
to do but just save this awp
eco extra frag if you possibly can but
that won't be the case
whatever zeus said to his team it must
have been pretty good james because that
was
a phenomenal round from them discarded
cast aside
abandoned by the very organization he'd
called home
zeus entered the grand finals of the
krakow major with
everything to prove and nothing to lose
steele only has one the bolts can play
off of him smoke on the bomb already
kiss for steal kits for steel who's the
one with one hp
getting closer getting closer first
knows he finds him and he backs away
king will be picked up
by bolts but zeus is going to sit on top
of it this will be the round that could
have exploded it's going to be john
wolf's going to get all the kills he
likes
damn it'll get their 13th round zeus
that's so big from him he knows it as
well
take it back because he thinks otherwise
they'll go aggressive no one peeking so
he'll take every inch he can get to make
this
an instant kill on the shotgun he's
found
steel trains and steel goes for more
it's done
damn that have done it
by winning that series zeus made history
on more than one count
for starters he became the oldest major
winner in history
at 29 years and 289 days old
he also cemented himself as inarguably
the greatest in-game leader the cis had
ever seen
and the one who was finally able to lead
the region to their first
cs go major lastly he became the first
player ever to make it to a major final
on two different teams
and unlike the times he'd been there
with navi his roster wasn't star-studded
he wasn't being hyped boosted or carried
he was just
being zeus like he always had
and as it turns out that was enough one
more very very
very important question for you you
tweeted
i will not give up till they win a
mother
in nature you just did that now what are
you gonna do i just say
all of maester i love you
and second god help me
and i won't measure
[Music]
the crazy thing is that he wasn't done
shortly after krakow zeus was invited to
rejoin navi
given that following his departure
they'd pretty much
floundered but zeus is back and there's
another chance for navi to become
that major winning team that they
perhaps always should have been
but weren't able to and with the young
gun who'd replaced zeus becoming both a
mentee
and probably the single greatest player
ever to touch the game by 2018
navi were back they don't expect flamie
come with the hour come on the man
flamer denies it all and surely it's
larvae
seconds away to the grand finals against
the odds
navi face down astralis and walk away
the victors
they have taken down the juggernaut
nobody thought astralis would be dropped
out of the semis
this is a different knobby than we're
used to what a play from the captain as
well
zeus carries them across the finish line
31-18 for him
but it's all done surely as they wrap
around electronic
fittingly finds the last kill 16-8 navi
will pick up finally a trophy they've
been waiting for
all year for the first time in 2018
none more deserving now they have won
in cologne and yes
people did continue to make fun of
zeus's lackluster mechanics
limbo
not to mention his questionable decision
making
oh here we go zeus doe finally does
something
he's captain why is my life like this
every chance i feel like i'm going to
sit home sometimes
things happen and just for you know
being zeus
has not a ferment tremendous excuse me
job of doing so drop down trying to find
who has he done that simple
why do you think you're so good i i tell
him he could
you you i was yours it's your secret
because
i play in gambit and simple don't best
back to navi why what's the secret your
success
before before you sell the secret to
adren
mvp major yeah but it didn't matter zeus
had won a [ __ ]
major he'd commandeered yet another
iteration of counter-strike
and went on to play in four more majors
he even made another grand
finals before skidding his 17-year
career to a much deserved halt in
september of 2019
and despite all of the criticism he'd
received over the years
everyone was sad to see him god
[Music]
everyone from brazil everyone from ibr
just like to say thank you seals for
everything you have done for counter
strike
and we always admire you my hat's off to
you my brother salute
zeus is one of the few competitors who's
been around since the very beginning of
counter-strike
not just from the current cs go
community for all the people who don't
know you from back in the early days of
1.6
when i first got to compete against you
in moscow i think one of my first
tournaments
always been a pleasure man always been a
great competitor and in that time he's
accomplished more than most people
dream of you people will ever have the
kind of success or the kind of longevity
that you had and you should be proud of
that
ultimately it doesn't matter what you
think about his haphazard and eccentric
leadership style
zeus is undeniably one of the greatest
players ever to touch csv
yes
you're free to disagree of course but
the beauty of titles is that no amount
of
punditry can take them away from you in
spite of his detractors
zeus has stood the test of time he's had
one of the most illustrious careers in
the history of counter-strike
and is by all accounts a legend
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell
for unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages
you